المترجم: Esraa Abo El-So'od
المدقّق: Modather Zaki
صباح الخير.
أنا شيرين عماد.
هل منكم من يعرف هذه السيدة؟
في مدينة ألاباما
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وتحديدًا يوم 1 ديسمبر عام 1955
صعدت هذه السيدة إلى الحافلة
من الباب الخلفي
للجلوس في أحد المقاعد المخصصة لها كواحدة
من الأفريقيين الأمريكيين أو الزنوج
بالتعبير الشائع حينها.
جلست في مقعدها وبعد فترة امتلأت الحافلة،
وصعد رجل أبيض ولم يجد مكانًا.
أوقف السائق الحافلة،
وتقدم إلى الصف التي كانت تجلس فيه
روزا باركس
وطلب منهم -الأربعة- النهوض من أماكنهم
ليجلس الرجل الأبيض.
نهض الثلاثة عداها، ورفضت بإباء شديد جدا.
تطور الأمر إلى عراك،
وبدأ في جرها من ذراعها ولكنها أصرت
على رفضها للنهوض.
اتسع نطاق الأمر وحدثت احتجاجات كبيرة جدًا
وأصبح النواة لأول حركة مدنية
حقوقية أمريكية في تاريخها المعاصر.
بعد عدة سنوات من هذا الموضوع،
كانت روزا باركس في مقابلة صحفية
وقالت: اعتقد الناس أني لم أنهض من مكاني
لكوني مرهقة جسديًا
وأن بعد يوم عمل طويل لم أرغب في النهوض.
لكن في الواقع كنت مرهقة من الاستسلام،
من الوضع العنصري البغيض الذي كنا نعيشه.
شعرت روزا بالغصة والغضب
لعدم تقبل المجتمع الأبيض لها.
عدم التقبل الذي تطور إلى عنصرية
ثم إلى عنصرية تدعمها الحكومة
والقانون في ذاك الوقت.
وكل هذا فقط لاختلاف أصول روزا،
لاختلاف لون بشرتها.
نحن في مجتمعنا الذي يتكون من أفراد:
فرد، وفرد وفرد،
هؤلاء الأفراد يولدون أطفالًا
والأطفال يولدون صفحة بيضاء،
لم يُخطَطْ عليها شيء.
من يكتب عليها هم الأسرة
والمدرسة والشارع والمجتمع
وللأسف الشديد ليس كل ما يكتب
إيجابي أو محمود.
الجملة التي نستخدمها دائما للتندر مثل:
سمراء ولكن خفيفة الظل
نستخدمها بشكل طبيعي، وغيرها من الجمل
وجمل نستخدمها تلقائيا دون تفكير
دون إدراك لتأثيرها على الفرد
الذي نوصمه بكونه مختلفًا
وعلى المجتمع ككل.
جمل نخرجها دون أي تفكير، نستخدمها
بكل بساطة، كالأكل والشرب
وأي نشاط عادي.
عرف علم النفس التقبل
بأنه قدرة الشخص على تقبل حقيقة أو واقع
أو موقف دون محاولة تغييره.
في حين عرفه علم النفس الاجتماعي
أنه قدرة الشخص على التسامح وتقبل الاختلاف
لشخص غيره أو مجموعة أخرى من الأشخاص.
أما نحن فماذا نفعل؟
وعلام ننشئ أولادنا؟
ننشئ أولادنا على أننا لن نتقبل المختلف
لن أقبلك بسبب مظهرك، لن أقبلك بسبب وزنك
لن أقبلك بسبب مستواك
الاجتماعي أو الاقتصادي
لن أقبلك، ولكن ربما،
حتى لا ألفظك تمامًا من مجتمعي
قد أبحث عن ميزة جيدة عندك، لا بأس.
أبراهام مازلو، عالم النفس الشهير
ظل يفكر: ما الذي يعطي لحياة الشخص قيمة؟
أو ما الاحتياجات الأساسية للأشخاص
التي تشعرهم بقيمة حياتهم
وأنهم حقًا أحياء؟
وتوصل إلى نظرية تسمى
(التسلسل الهرمي للاحتياجات).
قال أن الاحتياجات الأساسية للإنسان
على شكل هرم
قاعدته الأساسية تشمل الاحتياجات
التي تمكنه من العيش:
الأكل والشرب والمأوى ومصدر الرزق.
ثاني طبقة من هذا الهرم هو
الإحساس بالأمان؛
أن يشعر أنه في مأمن من الخوف
والمخاطر بكل أنواعها.
وثالث طبقة كانت
الاحتياج إلى الانتماء؛
أن يشعر أنه منتمٍ إلى مجتمع يتقبله كما هو
وأن تكون هناك حميمية
وود بين أفراد هذا المجتمع.
وهذا احتياج عندنا جميعا دون استثناء
ومن دونه لن يكون لحياتنا أي معنى.
أما نحن فعلام ننشئ أولادنا؟
أو كيف نتعامل مع بعضنا البعض؟
نحن ننشئهم ونتعامل مع بعضنا على أننا
لن نتقبل بعضنا إلا بشروط
لن أقبلك إلا عندما تمتلك شهادة جامعية
ولن أقبلك إلا عندما تكونين زوجة وأم
لن أقبلك إلا إذا كان مظهرك كذا
لن أقبلك إلا إذا كانت بشرتك لونها كذا
شروط توارثناها من المجتمع
والعادات والتقاليد
ونطبقها على غيرنا بمنتهى القسوة.
أنا وأنتم بشكل مؤكد في فترة ما من حياتنا
تعرضنا للرفض وعدم التقبل بسبب شيء عندنا؛
وزننا، أو حالتنا الاجتماعية،
أو حالتنا الاقتصادية
أو مستوانا التعليمي وغيرهم.
ونحن أيضًا رفضنا أناسًا مثلنا
ولكن رأيناهم مختلفين
ووضعنا لهم شروط حتى نتقبلهم
كلنا سواء في هذا الأمر، وجميعنا
في نفس الدائرة.
فما تأثير هذا على الصحة النفسية للإنسان؟
من نراه في الصورة هذا هو كيبلين ويليامز.
هو أستاذ جامعي في جامعة أمريكية.
يوما ما كان ينزه كلبه في الحديقة،
ورأى شخصين يلعبان لعبة الفريسبي
أو الطبق الطائر الذي يتقاذفونه بينهما
فطار هذا الطبق عنده، فقذفه لهم وظل الثلاثة
يلعبون معا لدقيقة أو دقيقة ونصف
وكان سعيدًا جدًا بهذه المشاركة اللطيفة
بعد فترة من الوقت بدأ هذان الشخصان
في اللعب مع بعضهما
وتجاهلوه وكأنه غير موجود من الأساس
وقف لم يجد ما يفعله فعاد إلى مكانه
وجلس مع كلبه
ثم قال أنه شعر بكمية إحراج
وغضب ورفض غير طبيعية
وتعجبت من داخلي كيف لي أن أشعر
بكل هذا الغضب والرفض
من مثل هذا الفعل البسيط، يبدو أن الأمر
ليس بتلك البساطة
وسأقوم بعمل بحث لمعرفة تأثير الرفض
وعدم التقبل على الصحة النفسية للإنسان.
وبالفعل أنهى البحث واشتهر
وأصبح بحثا عالميا، ووصلت نتيجته
للعالم أجمع.
أول ما أراه كمتخصصة من تأثيرات
الرفض على الحالة النفسية
أنه يسقط ثقة الإنسان بنفسه
وتتشوه نظرته لنفسه تماما.
وهو الباب الذي يدخل منه كل ما هو سيئ
ومعظم الأمراض النفسية تدخل منه:
من توتر، أو اكتئاب، أو محاولات انتحار
واللجوء لعلاقات غير محسوبة
واللجوء إلى إدمان الكحول والمخدرات
وإلى اعتناق أفكار متطرفة
فقط ليشعر أنه -باعتناقه لهذه الأفكار- مميز
أو أنه ينتمي إلى مجموعة تعتنق نفس الأفكار
فيشعر بالانتماء.
ضاعف هذا الألم والغضب والإحساس بالرفض
إلى مئات وآلاف وملايين
شيء مرعب
وهذا ما يعيشه مجتمعنا اليوم
مجتمعنا اليوم يعاني من الرفض
وما النتيجة؟
تمييز وإقصاء على كل المستويات
وحروب على كل المستويات:
حروب "كيبوردية" من وراء شاشات الحاسوب
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
نحارب بعضنا البعض
يقول كل منا للآخر: أرفضك لسبب كذا وكذا
فقط لأنك مختلف عني.
وما حل هذا؟
الحل هو أن نقول لا، كل منا يبدأ بنفسه
كل منا لديه العيوب الشخصية
لو فكر بها وتأملها جيدا،
سيعيها وبالتالي سيراعي ذلك
في تعامله مع الآخرين
وفي نظرته للآخرين.
يقول لا كما فعلت روزا باركس
ووضعت الحافلة التي كانت بها
والتي شهدت أول حادثة
في متحف، والتقط أوباما صورة بها
كرمز لمقاومة العنصرية والإقصاء.
ننشئ أطفالنا على أننا نتقبلكم كما أنتم
ونحبكم كما أنتم
ونريدكم هكذا مثلما أنتم
فيكبر الطفل ذو شخصية سوية، ويتقبل الآخرين
وغيرهم يتقبل الآخرين .. وهكذا، فيحدث صلاح
في حال المجتمع.
أختم بمقولة الفيلسوف والروائي الكندي
جون سول:
كل الدروس في الطب النفسي وفي علم النفس
وفي الثقافة في مئات السنوات الأخيرة
علمتنا أن تقبل الاختلاف
وليس البحث عن التشابهات
هو ما يجعل الإنسان يشعر بالانتماء
سواء على مستوى الحياة الخاصة أو العامة.
هم فعلوها إذن نحن نستطيع فعلها.
شكرا لاستماعكم.